Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
November 6th,
holy Shit,
dude.
I gotta stack my fucking Christmas shopping.
You know what?
You actually should at this point.
Wouldn't it be great?
It'd be great to just think of every fucking goddamn person out there that you
got to buy.
Four,
nine,
nine your kids.
All right.
You love your kids,
not your dog.
You love your dog,
right?
What else is dead is your kids and your dog.
This is what it is,
right?
You love your wife too,
but you know,
he noticed,
right?
Would it be great if you could just fucking go?
Just get it all fucking done.
Just call in sick one day.
You know exactly where you want to go.
Know Fuck gimme one at all.
He's give me fucking like a Dunkin donuts.
Gimme a two fucking jellies are fucking powdered sugar.
Fuck true.
Clay sent a curler except it's gifts,
you know?
Then you just have the lady down there,
wrap them for you.
The whole fucking,
I mean nice gifts though.
Nice thoughtful shit for like 10 15 fucking people,
but you just knock it out in four hours,
right?
Then you take these fake hayfever pills and you walk into word like,
oh good,
well good.
I'll be around.
I'll be in my cubicle.
What happened?
You did.
The whole fucking thing is done right?
And then you can just sit there and chill for two things.
You should fucking do.
I would,
this is what I'm actually talking out loud to myself and I'm not mad if you
listening.
All right?
Two things you gotta do.
You gotta do fucking cardio right through the new year because you know you're
going to eat and drink like a fucking pig.
You know what's happening.
All right.
You know it's the end of the year.
You know what I mean?
You get those few days off and you just start thinking,
what if we just always had days off and everybody just fucking coked and your
fucking drank and nobody gave a shit and there wasn't anything to do the next
day.
You know,
that wonderful feeling of actually living life while enjoying it as opposed to
looking at dread at you fucking watch as to this is the next fucking Monday's
coming,
you know,
so if you can just somehow knock it out,
you know what I mean?
Knock it out before the animal show up.
You know?
I mean,
it's just fucking,
it all starts on black Friday and then it just becomes fucking,
just bad fathers.
And I dunno what ended December and all of that shit.
So you knocked that out.
You do your half hour cardio every fucking day.
Go for it.
Whatever.
Fuck you do.
Eat a salad or some shit.
Just do something,
you know?
So,
you know,
as I'm sitting here drinking a fucking Miller high life doing this fucking
podcast,
um,
I should do that.
I should make a fucking list in my head right now.
All the nieces and nephews,
what do they want?
How old are they?
Bang,
boom.
I don't like that Internet shopping though.
You know,
you just go on Amazon.
You just go around,
just click and shit.
Some reason it's not as fucking cool.
Um,
I actually found it accidentally found this really cool toy store.
Of course I was going out to a bar,
okay.
And it was closed and everything,
but it actually had like wooden toys,
like cars and shit,
like dead,
like uh,
you know,
the way they used to make them,
they didn't make him that way when I was a kid.
I remember my day say that Krystal is cheap shit.
When I was a kid crisis there was made out of metal and warden that the tires
were wearing a rubber,
right.
And our shit was all fucking plastic and God knows what else.
She put it in your mouth and next thing you know,
you are bad at math and you couldn't read out loud.
So you had to start telling jokes.
That's what happened.
Everything.
I was born during a fucking time when any fucking toy when you were a kid,
if you were the little kid going through the oral stage,
you know what?
They just stick their whole fucking hand in their mouth.
All your little brothers and shit,
every fucking toy you had it,
they put it in their mouth.
That was it.
You know,
they went from an eighth soon,
went down to a B steward it,
and then they had all the colorful cereals with all that fucking shit in it.
They had fluff peanut butter and fluff sandwiches,
wheat man,
it was just fucking,
it was a sugar coma.
Um,
oh,
and I gotta tell you it was great.
Oh Jesus Christ.
You get a flood and other sandwich,
then you put it on the banana splits of the monkeys,
you know,
with the whole influence of the acid generation.
It's a good time,
dude.
I saw a guy on a motorcycle today had a sh fucking suicide shifter behind him.
I always thought they kind of put it right down to the side.
They had it behind him.
I was uh,
I was dropping off some stuff.
Um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm getting rid of a bunch of shit that I have.
Um,
I bet you won't believe what the,
I bought one of those fucking,
so what are those saws?
Card.
Not a table saw.
The one that you have just in head.
It's just handsaw.
I fucking bought a great one a few years ago cause I had this under,
I got into this whole thought process.
Then I was going to start fixing shit around the house and that was going to
start woodworking or some shit like in my forties you know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's over.
It's not going to happen.
You know what I mean?
Unless you go take a class.
I don't know what,
but I didn't have time for that shit.
So I bought this sink fucking top of the line thing.
I've had that thing for three years.
It's still in the fucking box.
And I finally just said,
Bill,
you got nothing to built.
Okay.
The problem with the House that you bought was everything was done by some
fucking asshole like you after it was built after it was built as a bunch of do
it yourself weekend warrior Horse Shit.
Okay,
so I took that.
I had this bicycle then it bought near.
She never used it.
She used it long enough to fuck up all the gears,
you know what I mean?
She didn't know that you could shift.
Well,
not pedaling.
You know,
I forget,
you know,
she's like 10 years younger than me,
so I forget.
I forget.
They just grew up with automatic cars and they don't understand that shit has to
be turning when you're fucking pull the leavers down.
So that thing was fucked up.
Uh,
some old juicer just shit that was going to take up space in the kitchen.
I'm getting rid of that shit.
I got a bunch of old drum shit I'm getting rid of,
by the way,
all my modern drummers,
all my drama,
uh,
Drum magazine magazines,
I'm getting rid of those things and I have like,
I have enough fucking drum videos to make a guard data to start a fucking music
store.
I never watch them.
There's a few that I'm going to keep the Steve Gadd up close to Tommy Aldridge.
One,
uh,
there's a couple that I,
that,
that I love.
Then I'm going to keep,
um,
maybe the Steve Smith's,
Kenny Aronoff,
but I have like a zillion other ones that like,
I just watched and they'd,
people were phenomenal,
but I just never learned anything from it.
David Garibaldi was a good one.
See this,
what's going to happen?
I'm going to go through the magazines because I know I've got a couple old ones,
like Tommy Lee,
there's a John Bonham tribute.
I'm not getting rid of those fucking things,
but the rest of them,
there's like a music school,
if anybody knows out here in la that I could just donate those things too.
They just,
they just like,
you know,
I'm not gonna be this.
I'm becoming like that fucking old lady,
you know,
or the guy who just doesn't throw any shit and he was shit out.
And I just have like,
I literally have like a decade and a half a fucking drum magazines and uh,
what am I doing with them?
You know,
I read them and I put them up on the shelf and then I get another one.
The next month they read it.
I put up on the shelf and I always think like,
oh yeah,
I'm going to go back to this one.
And I don't call back to it.
Then I forget whatever article,
whatever music that they wrote out,
I'm never going to fucking find it.
What am I doing with it?
Pass it on to somebody else.
Let them fucking use it.
You know.
Although what was good,
it was,
I was trying to fuck with,
uh,
was it where eagles dare,
iron maiden and I that one part that Doug [inaudible] dad is Piper Dat,
Dat,
Dat Gab like that patch.
I never know what the fuck he was doing because the drums are sold low and the
goddamn mix,
I can never figure it out.
And uh,
they actually had the music written out and a,
I did go on Youtube,
but the guy there mentioned that drum magazine ad it.
And Lo and behold,
I had that fucking issue but still still able to figure it out via youtube.
So I'm going to get rid of a bunch of shit like that.
And uh,
because now that my fucking house has done,
I would also like to have it be a breathable little fucking funkshway there.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I got to tell you,
even though the fucker kitchen has come to a grinding halt because of all the
wiring they had to do,
getting that fucking island out of there.
Ah,
it's the greatest fucking thing ever.
That adolescent fucking cow that I had laying in the middle of the fucking
fridge.
I mean we're middle of the Goddamn a kitchen.
Finally got that the fuck out of their cell.
Anyways,
but this isn't what I wanted to talk about this the Monday morning podcast,
my batteries written medium,
which means it's probably going to fucking cut out on me right before I get to
an hour.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about?
Uh,
oh Jesus.
I was so,
I was watching a bunch of football this weekend,
college and pro equally enjoyable.
I got to start sticking up for the NFL because now everybody is just piling on
talking about how their ratings are plummeting and all that shit.
What I think is they just,
they just,
they just got too broad based and now it's getting back to the numbers that it
realistically is.
You know what I mean?
It was almost like the housing bubble with someone who has a fucking shit shack
and for some reason it's worth 400 grand.
You're like,
that's worth 400 grand.
Yeah.
The way the market's going,
there's time next year it'll be worth 500 grand.
Right.
That shit.
And then eventually the doll just topples on itself.
And so we find just goes to a,
that is a shack that you shit.
You know,
I mean I shit every day so you know,
I'll give you a five grand for it eventually.
That's what happens.
I think the NFL where they just,
you know,
they went from fucking 26 teams in my lifetime to 28 to 30 to 32 to fucking
wearing pink for a whole month to solute in the fucking troops to have in Bruce
Springsteen play at the halftime to fucking having it Monday night now Thursday.
And then occasionally Saturday.
They just,
they got where they,
they got way too way too fucking big here
and now that they're just sort of adjusting it down,
they kind of went through there.
Phil Collins Eighties years,
you know,
just getting away from the prog rock shit that they did,
like the prog rock of
mmm.
The NFL was like the 60,
70,
50,
60 seventies.
Right.
Then in the 80s they kind of peaked,
you know,
and then once they got no nineties wasn't bad somewhere I guess in like the two
thousands,
I think it was like when Phil Collins started,
you know,
doing covers the like the supreme shit,
you can't hurry love.
And you know,
there's a girl that's been,
Oh man,
man,
uh,
sue sue,
sue you like half of his shit.
You couldn't even understand what it was.
I remember this dude,
he used to wear a fucking tank top cutoff with the Ghostbusters logo on love
Phil Collins.
And not only did I not like Ghostbusters never was into that fucking movie.
I,
I couldn't stand that,
that Phil Collins Shit somewhere along the line,
you know,
your honor was,
was when he started lecturing me about the homeless.
You know,
I came home,
you know,
I put on MTV,
I want Ed to stake them.
Right.
God knows what happened to me that day.
I flunked a test,
you know,
somebody beat me up for having orange fucking hair,
Aj,
I just want to sit down and he'd be reminded of this shit.
Right?
And all of a sudden he's at there,
oh think twice because it's another day for you and me can pay with days.
And I remember just watching that video going,
what the fuck happened to his lip?
You know,
is he a squealer?
Why's he got that little mark or the squealer run that he's still a song
anyways,
but when I'm,
what I'm really meant to say is it's,
it's great that he's back.
It's great that he's gone back out on tour.
One of the greatest fucking drummers of all fucking time.
Um,
I dunno,
it's just somewhere around in the air tonight.
Then what are all that shit after that?
The Mike and the mechanics shit,
all of that fucking shit.
It just,
it,
it's the,
uh,
you know,
what never came back is the sound of the synthesizer.
It just is no way to make that sound quality.
It,
I don't know what the fuck do I know,
but just my own fucking opinion.
I just,
I just feel like it's just,
it doesn't have any soul,
you know?
Oh,
Jesus,
but why don't you shut the fuck up.
Okay.
I,
well,
let's,
let's talk about these new Hillary Clinton fucking commercials,
which of course none of,
and the Trump ones,
none of them talk about any sort of issue.
They're just sort of talking about each other.
But what assholes they are,
you know,
it's like a,
it's like two seventh grade girls just fucking starting rumors about each other.
They're not talking about the nature wide heroin epidemic then are talking about
fuck,
uh,
the pharmaceutical companies trying to fucking make,
we'd not legal at a state level again,
because all the states where that's fucking legal.
You know,
the,
the prescription medic,
uh,
prescriptions are all down.
They're losing money.
So they're going to try to demonize it again,
according to the person that I can't even remember who the fuck it is that told
me that.
And then I never read it to see if it's true.
But now I'm telling it to you.
I'm not talking about any of that shit.
Great Barrier Reef is dead.
Who gives a fuck.
Right.
All right,
let's trash the Hillary one first.
All right.
The Hillary one about fucking Donald Trump is they're trying to go.
Your kids are watching this.
What kind of precedent or are they going to see?
Okay,
which I get all right.
This kids that are into politics,
but they show like six year olds like riveted.
Just talk to a fucking eye
to a fucking adult running run for office.
I did you remember when you were six years old,
were you,
I don't even if what kids see nowadays when I was a kid,
when your parents put on the fucking news,
remember that feeling in your stomach or was she was like they were making eats
spinach.
You're like,
Oh my God,
I've got to get outta here.
This is boring.
Anytime there were adults on TV,
was suits talking?
It was over.
I wanted nothing to do with ally and what cartoons.
I like sports.
The bionic man.
What else did they have back then?
Little House in the prairie I liked for a little while and then it got it got
old gross when fucking they brought that kid who,
who did he go?
Definitely go black camera.
Remember what the fucking Adam kid or some shit he started fucking the one with
the pig tails.
It just got gross man.
I don't know.
I used to like watching the cowboys shit.
I like that,
that stuff.
But anything that was remotely nightly news,
politics.
I vaguely remember a Richard Nixon crying
on the radio when I was riding,
I was riding in the car with my mother and she was trying to explain to me what
was happening and I was like,
Oh wow,
okay.
And I never thought like,
like wow,
this guy lied to the nation.
This is a president crying on the radio.
I had no concept of any of that.
I was just like,
all right,
can I get out of the car right now because it's sunny out.
We've been driving for a while and I think I'm going to throw up.
That's all I was thinking cause I was a fucking kid.
Okay.
People,
here's the deal.
I mean,
how fucking awful are you that you got to start talking about kids,
kids are watching this guy.
Um,
and then the Hillary one,
I don't even know what the fuck or was it looked like a fucking pink Floyd
video.
I only,
I was cooking and I turned around.
I have,
I had the game on.
I'm the one that Trump made about Hillary,
uh,
which I want to say it was somebody dressed up like Hillary holding a pick ax or
something.
Like,
I didn't even know.
I never took a hallucinogen,
but you know,
that commercial maybe be like,
you know,
this would have been a great time
to done some acid to just watch that and like,
you know,
if he somehow made it like feature length,
that would have been fucking awesome.
But anyways,
I believe that the election is this week,
I want to say it's Wednesday or is it Tuesday?
Maybe it's fucking Tuesday.
I have no idea.
Um,
I know Wednesday the ninth I'm going to be on Conan O'brien and there will be a
new president.
Is it going to be the first layer?
Hmm.
You know,
which means Bill Clinton will be the first.
Yeah.
What the fuck would he be?
What we'd be called the first husband?
The first first husband I knew I'd be groundbreaking.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine if that fucking cigar fucking sticking lunatic is back in there
and now he does even have a fucking job.
Jesus Christ.
Hillary the first day is going to be like,
get all these brides the fuck outta here.
I'm president.
Get up anything.
What?
The twine.
Get it the fuck off Pennsylvania Avenue.
That's it.
They literally gonna they're gonna have to fucking wheel bill around like
Hannibal Lecter on like one of those two wheelers.
You know what I mean?
With the little fucking muzzle on them.
Jesus.
That animal might be coming back.
I think he's going to,
I think,
uh,
I think Trump fucked up.
He just said too much crazy shit.
And uh,
he made the Clintons look sane and he's got no one to blame but himself.
That's my prediction.
All right.
If I was a betting man and I was going to Vegas,
unbelievable.
Right.
And Bernie Sanders is like that school that should have been allowed into the
play off.
It didn't fucking get in right cause all these fucking cops were too afraid to
vote for him because,
oh there's no way you could word.
I saw somebody the other day on TV.
They did this whole fuck they did this.
They go I will.
Hillary has decay.
You got to make a smart decision either cause it's really hard.
This decision is really hard because Hillary had a bunch of felonies and Trump
and then they listed like all the shit that Trump did for like a minute.
This is like a fucking like a TV show.
I was just so fucking irresponsible I feel.
You know what I mean?
He's supposed to try to be like impartial,
right.
I bond being impartial.
I don't fucking like either one of them.
I just don't know how you trash one guy for fucking 90 God damn seconds and then
you just,
you and all you say about the other person is just their felonies.
Why don't you just talk about the felonies that were brought up that the charges
of those things.
You could talk about that for fucking 19 hours.
Oh No.
She has a blue bra,
so therefore she must be a saint.
I'm off my fucking soapbox here.
Good luck to you guys.
I really mean that.
Good luck to you,
man.
I hope,
uh,
somehow we come out of this,
we some out pick the fucking lesser of two fucking evils,
whatever that is.
And I hope everybody reads and rereads all the propositions and all this shit
that's attached to them.
I plan on fucking doing that for the first time ever.
I'm actually going to be an informed fucking voter when it comes to that shit
because I don't think there's any winning at the presidential level.
No,
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
whoever wins,
it's going to be a rough four years of speeches before the next one.
I mean,
neither one of them are good public speaker.
Holy Shit.
I mean,
Trump just goes out there and wings it like Trump.
When Trump gives a speech,
he sounds like he's waiting for the headliner.
He was like stretching,
waiting for the headliner to show up.
It keeps looking at the back of the room and they're still making that stretch.
See,
he's not here yet.
They said he's on his way.
Do another 10.
Um,
and then Hillary with that whole bobble head fucking thing that she does like
she is,
I haven't seen anybody so outside their own fucking body since Al Gore.
Remember Al Gore when he was fucking,
I never forget he was doing a debate with George Bush and George Bush makes a
point.
And then for whatever reason,
Al Gore's stood up,
walked all the way over to George Bush and just goes my turn.
And is Aaron Bush does like a double take like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Sort of a natural reaction to this guy coming out.
And I mean you could literally feel is fucking breath in his ear.
He fucking did this.
Double take looking at them and the whole crowd laughed at Al Gore.
And then Al Gore just threw his head back and for whatever reason started
laughing just goes,
ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And I'm like,
what are you laughing at?
Like what the fuck are you doing?
Okay.
Like he,
he was a,
yeah,
that guy deck.
You know what that guy,
that guy read about his critics too much.
Like the first time they were like,
uh,
he wasn't animated enough and the next time you went out there,
he's doing like this Fossey Shit.
Um,
though Jesus Hebrew,
he redefined fucking flop.
Sweat that guy.
All right,
let's get out of politics.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking anyways,
talking about here.
Let's do a little bit of advertising.
20 minutes into the kiss.
There are right Indochino Indochino Indo Chino,
who knows.
Talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
All right.
You know what?
Everybody,
I think guys look good by,
I think they look even better in itself.
A look at that.
Yeah.
I actually don't think I,
it depends on where you're going.
All right.
Depends on what's going on.
Okay.
If I just had a fucking accident and somebody comes walking up to me in a suit,
I'm like,
this piece of shit is going to fucking destroy me in court.
That's what I think.
You know what I mean?
It all depends on the suit,
you know?
But if you take a lady out,
you know,
if you're going out to dinner,
you wear a suit.
That's when you look better.
Okay.
If I'm sitting across the desk and I needed a job and you've got the guys in the
fucking suit,
uh,
you know,
breathing heavy,
they're not,
you don't look better in a suit.
You know what I mean?
Although you know what's great about students?
If you're a fat fuck,
you can't really see the man Ted so much.
You put the coat on,
so that's good.
All right.
Is that good enough?
Indochino Indo Chino is one of the largest made to measure men's wear brands.
They are making it easy for men to get great fitting,
high quality suits and shirts at an incredible price.
How does that work?
Well,
just visit indochino.com or drop by one of their nine North American show rooms.
Uh,
pick from hundreds of fabrics and patterns.
Choose your customizations from lapels to pleats to jacket linings and more.
That's pretty cool though.
I like,
you know,
now that he ordered a car when that start ordering your so it's right.
They have a fucking crazy lining.
Remember that Eddie Murphy movie when the dude open it up and he went,
ah,
um,
submit your own body measurements,
kick back,
relax,
and get ready to step into the best,
most stylish suits you've ever worn in just four weeks.
Unless she channeled like a fucking pig,
then it won't fit this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for $300 and 8,389
dollars@indochino.com when entering bird checkout,
that's 50% off regular prices made to fuck man.
Premium suit plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com I.
It's like Indo in China accepts.
Oh,
China.
Like how a sting would say if he was touring in China,
staying way.
You're touring this.
Uh,
we joined the summer and
in Dope jato.com promo code birth for any premium suit for $389 and free
shipping and dope job also has amazing holiday deals right now on their shirts,
their pants and other products too.
You'll never have to worry about,
uh,
about badly fitting suits or expensive trips to the tailor.
Again,
get ready to look like 1 million bucks for only $389.
Okay,
there we say 1 million bucks.
If you pay in train and get ready and look like five grand,
that would look great to the few look like you were wearing a $5,000.
So there was 1 million bucks.
All right,
Luke Craig,
give me
on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Luke Craig offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical Fashionista than try Luke where monthly wearables
and accessories with cult classics and your favorite franchises.
If you want to get fancy,
get a big uh,
box and even bigger loop with loot crate DX.
Get ready for Novembers and chanting theme magic.
Oh Jesus.
What the fuck is this shit?
Loot crate has cast a powerful ancient spell.
They'll deliver you November's crate featuring be witching items from Dr.
Strange,
fantastic beasts,
not the regular beast.
Fantastic piece.
Don't say that about yourself.
You're fantastic.
And where to find them?
Big trouble.
Little China.
I fucking love that movie.
And so much more.
Uh,
do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for Novembers crate.
How to fuck this big trouble in little China end up in the magical thing.
I remember there was like the guy they were trying to kill.
He was a little magical,
but other than that,
it was Kurt Russell eat another sandwich,
driving a truck,
if I remember.
All right.
When it's over,
it's over.
No more crates.
Go to Luke craig.com/burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription subscription today.
You can do that in the u s orange.
All right.
Oh Geez.
Is Little coups back little Kudo fucks bag.
Betty boop,
boop,
boop.
Biondi Biondi so together
shine.
Obo Do do
Mandy's me undies
Malone year as whole.
It feels nice and soft upon your tastes.
They might get wet,
but then they yay cause they dry up.
All the moisture from your nod said they gained even dry out your clamp if it's
sweaty.
All right,
me undies.
Picture a picture.
A world we're putting on a new pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
God,
Daddy,
feel good.
Think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put on and then it's the last thing you take
off.
Unless you're a fucking Weirdo.
Why would you settle for anything less?
What if you just took off your pants and your underwear?
He kept on your socks and your shoes you had on a vest and a bowler hat,
right?
And you just came running around the corner,
not knowing what you're going to come out.
Jesus,
that's a fucking youtube,
but you get 100 million hits on that.
All right.
Why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Because I'm easy to please,
you know,
as long as it covers my nuts,
I never really thought about it to be honest with you.
Me On.
If you're really asking me if that's number Torical,
please include all of the following points during your reads.
Absolutely.
Me undies focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
That's all they do.
My friends have Anelli at [inaudible] sent me a few pair of while back.
Yes,
they dead and now I can't imagine wearing anything else.
That's a crock of shit.
And you never gave me any other ones.
One of them fed good.
The other ones were a little too Greg Louganis,
if you know what I mean here.
Um,
it really makes each day that much better.
I'm one of those guys.
I've,
I think I,
I just buy underwear.
It was,
I just feel like I need it,
you know?
And uh,
but there's definitely shit in the rotation that's been in the league for a
while.
You know,
since George Bush's first term,
you know,
I just,
they just don't wear out.
You know,
the covered up.
They're fine.
All right,
for the price of two cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guaranteed.
Try them on if they aren't the most weighty,
go inside first people try them on.
And if they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling undies you've ever had,
they'll refresh,
refined you and that you keep your first pair of for free.
Included in the price is the sweet touch of modal.
Oh,
just cup and it's fucking balls,
you know?
But you said yes.
Okay.
No means no,
but you said yes.
The model,
a special fabric that's made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
That has to be true because the cotton,
the lobby never came back like,
hey man,
it's only 2.5 times.
These Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on the [inaudible].
These websites where you'll enjoy free shipping and the U s plus Canada and for
a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order.
But you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr with the me undies.
Better Day guarantee you have nothing to lose,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash burr a righty.
Um,
okay,
well I did something a little weird this week,
right?
What did I do here?
I fucking,
I tried to be slick hair and what I did was I copied and pasted only three of
the reads,
three of the six.
So then I could immediately go into the questions.
But then you know,
I also want other shit that I wanted to talk about and it's all the way up here
at the top.
See,
this is the problem.
When you fuck with your daily routine.
All right.
What the fuck is this?
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
Just relax.
Relax.
It's almost done.
Okay.
It's done.
All right.
What else do I want to talk to it?
How great it was.
The fucking giants eagles game.
Huh?
That's always a great game.
And the same thing happens every fucking year.
The giants go up,
they go up fucking big and then the eagle start coming back and most of the
times they giants just can't fucking put them away today.
They did.
I fucking love the NFC east.
And uh,
I've watched so many giants games because of Versie.
I actually root for the giants.
I shouldn't be doing that as a pat fed,
you know,
I don't,
you know what it is.
I just,
I don't have that fucking sports fan in me just because we lost to the fucking
giants.
I mean,
did they,
did we robbed now we weren't.
The guy did it to us twice.
He's fucking great for me to not like Eli would be,
I'd have to not like Tom Brady.
Cause then I'm saying I don't like greatness.
Plus,
w one of the most interesting things to do is to watch Eli manning throughout
the course of a football season.
I'm telling you,
this is when he starts waking up.
He's fucking bored.
It's September,
October,
eh,
it stretches a little bit in November,
and then when they need to win the last six,
seven fucking games are all through out of the playoffs.
Then he starts playing like a champ and they get on a fucking roll.
I'm telling you if this guy knows what he's doing,
whereas his brother from day one was,
are are protection your shoes.
He went out there like a fucking lunatic from day one.
I think he burned himself up by the time he got to the playoffs.
I don't know.
That's just a theory.
Got,
dammit.
That's a delicious beer.
Every once in a while,
you know,
every once in a while,
you just take what you'd take a sip of a beer and it takes you back to the first
time you got fucking hammered,
you know?
Where were you the first time he got drunk?
I was at Faneuil Hall in Boston.
You know,
a stone's throw from the comedy connection where I would be performing a mere
eight years later,
right.
And I was drinking Michelob lights.
So the only place I've ever been able to find Michelob light is in New Orleans.
And a,
I always drink one.
Whenever I go down there,
that's a tradition.
Some people go down there,
they go down there for the Gumbo or the fucking,
uh,
we'll creole fucking whatever the fuck the music and all that call that shit.
I go down there,
there's this store,
it's right down by where the fucking Choo Choo train goes down the street there
and they sell,
it says fucking shit off.
It's down near there,
Harris,
it's legal liquor store and you know,
it's got all this bullshit now and they go,
I always buy,
I buy a single and I just fucking walk around,
listen to the music,
trying to not make eye contact with the unbelievable amount of shady fucking
people in New Orleans.
One of the most shady as fuck.
And I can honestly say that dude,
like there,
there is something,
something wrong with that city in a good way.
And in a bad way,
I'm telling you it's fucking good.
So I love the city.
Absolutely fucking love it,
but it's got some of this shady as fucking people I've ever seen in my life.
And,
and am just not blaming the locals,
the fucking people that show up down there,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I mean Berberine Street,
like no young people go there.
You know what I mean?
Going to Bourbon Street is,
is like,
that was,
I don't know,
when it stopped being cool somewhere with my generation born,
I go on Bourbon Street,
even during the day,
the fucking shit show it is.
And I just see these bloated fucking people from my generation with the tramp
stamps,
the wire and tribal tattoos going around these fucking guys with these
grandmother,
flabby arms,
man.
But you know what it is,
dude,
they had kids,
you know,
so I was able to stay in show Biz cause uh,
I ain't no Fada so,
um,
I dunno,
but the fucking humanity that I see down there,
it's just,
it's just not dying.
It's just fucking ridiculous.
All right,
let's,
um,
let's move on and let's talk a little bit of college football.
Fucking,
I'm about Lsu,
man.
What a game they gave Alabama,
man,
that was not a fucking easy game.
No one Alabama.
Which
that
all right.
That's how everybody in northern Alabama speaks.
It's unbelievable.
You get down near Auburn,
like all of a sudden people would just speaking eloquently,
you know,
Ladies Gentlemen,
you get to the north man,
you get north up there,
you know,
you start getting close to at Tennessee border.
You don't know what the fuck you're going to run into.
Okay?
Those are crazy people,
right?
Like powers booth should be in a swamp.
You know what I mean?
Little southern comfort up there.
You know,
if you get down,
you know,
mobile,
Alabama,
you know Auburn University though,
those,
you know,
it was a great people.
Mobile,
Alabama.
I mean,
how many fucking battleships did they build,
you know,
or World War Two.
What the fuck were they doing up at Crimson tide country?
They weren't doing shit.
Oh,
they doing up there?
Huh?
Fucking looking at this stills.
Um,
I'm just fucking with you.
I don't know how the fuck I ended up.
Jesus Christ,
look at the fucking cheerlead is on the 40.
Niners
I'm sorry,
I got the NFL network playing in the
background.
I'm watching.
Uh,
Colin Kaepernick.
Oh look,
he almost broke it.
31 to 24.
The one in six San Francisco fucking 40 niners dead down to the three and four
New Orleans,
New Orleans saints.
These were great games this week.
You know,
I got to tell you this,
this is how my weekend goes.
I always watched the fucking patriots.
All right.
And I always watched the fern Lundquist Gary Danielson game,
uh,
college football.
And then I always watched the Joe Buck,
Troy Aikman game plus the Patriots.
I mean,
if you fucking do that,
there's no way you're not going to like football.
I don't know what this bullshit is about.
I'll,
you know,
all these people running away from the fucking game and the games change,
and this is a fucking great game.
This game right here at 31 to 20,
right?
It's nine minutes fucking left.
Cap Her next,
driving
down the failed.
We get to learn.
Jesus Christ 88.
What are you doing?
He's got on a breath,
right strip.
He should get,
he should have an a fucking catch right strip there.
Hit you right in your fucking hands.
You asshole.
Nine 21 to go in the third.
If anybody's taping the game,
Colin Kaepernick somehow get the Afro underneath the fucking the fucking helmet.
Look at this duck hunter.
Looking at the place.
This guy looks confused.
All right.
They're lining up for the play.
All right,
and in the center column
98.
Yeah.
Bravo 72 to Mike [inaudible].
He's on.
Well,
you walked away.
They walked away.
What are they doing?
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
I thought something exciting was going to happen.
You don't need to look for that.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
I barely been watching my Bruins.
I know we beat Tampa Bay.
Then we lost to the fucking ranges,
which I think they've already beaten this twice this year.
And uh,
I know Tampa Bay has a legitimate shot to get to the Stanley Cup.
Uh,
I don't know where the rangers are wrapped,
but I just feel like we're in another middle of the road kind of team.
But,
um,
well my kitchen is done.
What kitchen has done it and I can get back to my fucking house where I have,
I have all the sports packages people,
I get the NBA fucking hardcore,
whatever the fuck they call it.
I got the NHL Center ice,
I got Nfl Sunday ticket,
I watch the Formula One.
This is what the fuck I do.
I have no life.
I watch all of this shit.
I watch college football,
you know,
and for whatever reason,
my wife leaves me alone and let's me do it,
which is probably why I married,
you know,
that's the deal.
If you want to know if you're with the right woman,
order all the sports packages and just see how she fucking handles that.
Um,
I got to tell you,
she's had some,
she had some people over this week,
right?
Some of her relatives and shit.
And like,
it's all women.
All fucking ladies.
Right?
And they're in there watching this car Dashi and shit.
So I walk in,
there's one TV in the house,
and I go,
okay,
I'm going to be on my best fucking behavior.
I lasted like,
I think I lasted three minutes.
I was what they were watching,
keeping up with the Kardashians,
and I was literally watching two of them driving on the four oh five freeway
talking about nothing like the bearded guys going,
oh my God,
look at that lady when she does a lady in the car next door.
She got,
she has on a fucking mass,
but the fucks with her,
and then the other girl was like,
I want to get some yogurt.
Let's get some frozen yogurt.
Why are you watching this?
And they're like,
riveted.
They'd like,
they,
they cannot get enough of it,
you know?
Meanwhile,
I'm like three episodes behind.
I'm sealing on episode two of a,
of Westworld.
Yeah.
No,
I've been watching Westworld and I've been watching Atlanta who Chris Rock said,
that's the best show on TV,
right?
I think he's a little biased.
You know?
I think it was a little fucking lighter skinned like me.
He'd also like fucking Westworld,
but they're both phenomenal,
phenomenal fucking shows.
Uh,
highly recommend both of them,
the way they're shot.
I mean,
Atlanta looks like a fucking,
it was like an award winning movie every single episode,
right?
Just some of the shots that they get and the writings.
Unbelievable.
And a Westworld is just a whole other level for me.
So I got to get caught up with all of that shit.
But enough of my ramblings.
Let's get into some of the,
uh,
the questions here for the week that people have.
You know,
I mentioned,
uh,
you know,
all of that topless shit,
like why women want to do it or certain women want to do it.
Like that's coming up again here this week.
Let's see.
Uh,
I guess that's not for a couple of here.
Gave you a little teaser there.
All right.
Nat Geo Lee,
Leo Dicaprio documentary.
All right.
Nat Geo,
National Geographic and Leonardo Dicaprio made this great documentary about
climate change and I think you would love it.
It's free on youtube until November 6th after that.
Probably costs a few dollars.
If you'd watch it.
I'd love to hear your thoughts about it on the podcast.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you,
I'm,
I'm terrified to watch it.
I'm terrified to watch all of that cause that's the shit that these two fucking
dopes that are running for office should be talking about.
And they don't,
they just make fucking commercials about how the other person's an asshole.
But I,
you know what I'll do?
I'll check it out.
I'll check it out when it,
what if I ignore it?
Does that mean it's not happening?
Um,
you know something,
I'm going to tweet out the link here and you guys can watch it if you want to.
I'm not trying to be that guy.
Fortunate politics down your fucking throat or trying to ruin your fucking
avocado and toast sandwich there,
but if you want to watch it,
check it out.
Alright.
Uh,
who's who is buying million dollar condos in la?
This is what I asked out here because there is this massive amount of building
going on here to buy an apartment out.
Building out here is just so fucking high.
It's ridiculous.
Anybody with half a fucking brain is not buying right now cause it's all going
to fucking crash.
This happens every fucking take a full three,
four,
five years cycle.
Every fucking time.
You can't lose.
There's no way to lose.
You can't fucking lose.
One day you wake up right there,
Fred,
you're lost to go fuck himself.
Um,
and then,
then the smart people then swoop in and it's,
you're crying with your pockets turned inside out.
They come in and actually pay less than what you paid in less than the market
value.
Those are the guys that fucking win.
Um,
so here we go.
A bill that Chinese and other foreign investors are buying up expensive real
estate in major US markets because our currency is more stable than their
homelands.
Ah,
okay.
May or may not be another bubble,
but definitely makes it so regular folk have a hard time finding a place to
live.
Just type Chinese buying into Google and see what it auto fills go.
Eagle swell.
I sorry about she eagles.
Uh,
they did play a great game though,
um,
to allow scariest fucking sprawls.
Oh my God,
I'm so glad that guy's not in my fucking division.
He almost took it.
He did.
He take another one backer.
He almost took one back.
That's right.
They knocked them out of like the 15 yard line.
He does that every fucking year to the giants it seems.
Anyways.
Um,
all right,
well here's my question.
If that's like a safe thing to do,
like say that dollar was crashing and all of a sudden I started buying shit in
France.
I wouldn't overpay for it.
Well,
maybe they're crashed and so quick they don't give a fuck that they overpaid for
Ra Chinese.
John Chinese.
Uh,
first thing that comes up is food.
Hang on a second.
What was I supposed to look up?
Chinese buying.
All right,
here we go.
Buying Useu you say no to Chinese.
China buying the world.
Are they buying the world?
China's Dalian.
Wanda group buys Dick Clark productions for 1 billion.
Now.
What of that's really well put.
The fuck is going on there.
There wasn't an American Chinese guy who could have done it a day or we got to
keep Dick Clark stuff on this side of the border.
And if elected,
I don't even know what the guy owns.
Wealthy Chinese buyers are growing a growing force in US real estate.
All right,
this one seems a little bit,
okay.
This is the Washington Post.
This seems a little more tethered here to the ground here.
Um,
after a long and painful slide falling the real estate collapse in 2008,
Seattle's property market isn't joining one of the sharpest rises anywhere in
the u s Boyd by a rapidly expanding economy,
there has brought tens of thousands of high paying jobs to the city.
Real estate values have nearly doubled since 2000,
since 2009,
according to online real estate database,
Zillow.
Oh,
is that really credible?
Zillow's not credible by the way,
cause I see what they,
what they say,
what my house is worth and what the fuck I paid for it.
It's not even that they're not right.
All right.
Yet while technology,
uh,
billionaires gobbles up real estate from Puget sound and Lake Washington,
Jim Conlin or real estate broker and the [inaudible] on Canva,
um,
says the real estate careless for sites for the dramatic upswing can be found in
China.
To be honest,
Chinese buyers have been flooding this market for the past few years.
Some of them buy homes sight unseen while others traveled here for a kind of
real estate tourism and buy real estate after only one viewing.
Oh,
all right.
is that bad?
Okay.
Why would that be bad?
Like what,
what exactly could happen if they're buying it all up?
I guess that's driving the price up.
You know,
the banks did it in 2008
at least.
These fucking people have money.
You know,
it's not like back in the day when you made $40 working in a soup kitchen and
they go,
hey,
you want to buy a fucking house for 400 grand?
You qualified,
do I?
Yes.
Sign here.
Um,
so that's better than the last thing.
All right,
well maybe it isn't a bubble.
All I know is I can't compete with these cons.
So my dream of buying a a apartment building in La is rapidly diminishing.
I got an idea.
How by,
when are you people,
you know,
can I invest with you?
Can I take,
can I take 15% of the fucking risk?
I'll do that.
Come on.
When are you fuckers has gotta be listening to this on your Chinese Internet?
He allowed to do it.
So many in Kong.
I've been out there.
I did a fucking show where it was you.
All right.
Indigo girls.
Hey Bill.
So when I was growing up,
my mom really loved the indigo girls,
so,
so did I.
I went to the doctor.
Fucking is all right.
And she wrote in parenthesis,
no,
she wasn't a lesbian.
What does that have to do is just Chris,
are they lesbians?
I assume?
I don't know why I thought if they were,
you know,
I don't know if it was the Woodstock fucking from peanuts haircut,
you know that a lot of them favor,
I don't know.
It's really funny how different groups of people,
they just favor a haircut,
like rednecks just loved the mullet,
you know what I mean?
Boston psychos for a while.
The big thing was to shave,
like to have no sideburns and just have the straight line,
you know?
Right.
Above year year,
they went to the back to some sort of rat tail,
you know those people with their fucking shell toed,
Adidas Nicoletta Claddagh Dude.
So anyways,
so probably the first five concerts I went to were indigo girls.
I specifically remember calling into Oh one oh 7.3 w a f I remember that.
Debbie AOL.
Oh,
kick ass.
Rock and roll was WC.
Oh,
Z,
okay.
Waf was on Wooster needs to go Worcester,
Boston.
It's just like,
well what is it?
And then it's Worcester and Boston fuck in Massachusetts.
They were actually on worster,
if I remember correctly.
MMM.
Fucking Boston,
Massachusetts kid and asking a Dj for tickets to something because I had only
ever seen the indigo girls and he asked if we had a 12 inch sausage in the
freezer.
I didn't get it at the time.
Hey,
I still really liked him,
but I don't listen to folk rock that much more anymore.
Can you believe how just openly like homophobic and crazy people could be back
in the day?
Yeah.
That indigo girls singing from the podcast had me belly laughing at my fucking
desk at work to the point where people were giving me dirty look.
Fucking Christ.
Thank you man.
Seriously.
That was the best.
Uh,
yeah.
Indigo girls are great.
Um,
I haven't seen only one song that I know.
MMM.
Closer.
I am to five.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember that song.
All right.
Feminist Fan.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Hey Bill,
I'm a huge fan and a big old feminist.
All right.
Welcome.
How are you?
Uh,
my husband played me your epidemic of gold digging whores bid on our third date
and I went from hating you to almost pissing myself laughing in three seconds.
I would love to know what bid I did that made you hate me or did you just look
at me,
which I understand.
She said I'd been a devoted fan and a podcast listener ever since.
Probably once a month.
I'll write a very heartfelt and sincere email to you about something you said,
but then you make an endearing comment like,
uh,
then you'll make an endearing comment.
What the fuck do I know?
I'm a moron.
And I realized that I'm also a moron and you're a comedian.
I shouldn't take things so seriously.
So I delete the email and move on.
Yeah.
You know,
it's called being an adult may know that I'm a fucking dope.
And then you realize it that I admitted that I was a dope.
So then you don't have to be all fucking taking shit seriously.
Was that too intellectual people with all the F words in there?
She said,
but with this election,
I still feel I have to write in Ah,
son of a bitch.
You just waltzed me around the warm Rome.
You got me all warm and fuzzy now he had comes to fucking write up the fucking,
yet I gave it comes to the uppercut.
But with this election stuff,
I feel like I have to write in.
Okay.
I totally get where you're coming from on how corrupt the Clintons are.
This is what every Clinton support.
I get it.
She's the devil.
Having said that,
now I'm going to talk 15 minutes about how fucked up Trump is there.
They're both fucking horrific.
Anyways,
she goes and she goes,
okay,
all right,
let me start.
Let me at least give her the chance to fucking say her opinion here.
Before I fucking jumped back up on my pasty soapbox here.
She said,
I totally get where you're coming from and how corrupt the Clintons are and how
fucked up the whole system is and that the Illuminati is probably pulling the
strings either way.
Uh,
but I'm,
I'm fucking around when I say that.
I just think people are,
they get a little nuts when they get a lot of power anyways,
but on major things you seem to care about,
like the environment and corporate influence on politics.
Trump is on the opposite side of the spectrum for you as is Hillary Clinton
as his Obama.
What the fuck did Obama ever do?
What of Democrats or Republicans,
they don't do fucking shit.
They don't do anything about any of that fucking,
uh,
any of the shit that's going on out there.
They don't do anything because they need all of their fucking money.
So stop with this.
Fucking,
they wearing light blue and they care about the butterflies.
Hillary Clinton doesn't give a flying fuck about anything,
but what other next price of zillion dollar real estate she could park her
fucking corrupt twat on.
That felt good,
right?
If old orange,
if then orange wicked cut doesn't get there first.
Whew.
Okay.
It's like Clintonism mechanic that's been working on your car for years and the
car runs,
but there's always some issue with it.
And even though she'll throw in a free air freshener now and then she's always
pulling shit,
like getting you to replace your shots,
you need to,
I don't know anything about cars.
I'm hoping this analogy makes sense.
I'm trying to relate to you.
So you're like,
fuck it.
I'm not gonna I'm not going with Clinton anymore.
Um,
I,
I think I kind of get what you're saying that,
but you're really over simplifying this as does everybody when they're defending
the person that they're gonna vote for.
I just want you as a fucking human being to just say that Hillary Clinton,
you know,
is a horrific choice.
The same way Trump is,
that they're fucking horrific choices.
No matter how you slice it.
You know,
if the best thing you say about Clinton is she's not Trump,
right?
And the best of the best he said about Trump and early,
she's not Clinton.
I mean,
to be honest with you there,
they're fucking,
they're animals.
Uh,
sorry.
but then Trump is some dude on your blog who has three rusted out cars in his
backyard.
No,
he isn't.
He's constantly defaulting on debt.
No,
he doesn't.
And none of his neighbors have anything nice to say about him.
He,
we went bankrupt like three,
four times.
He took advantage of the bankruptcy laws,
which is totally fucking legal.
He's always talking about every professional mechanic is a swindling asshole.
I'll give you that.
And he tells you to leave your car with him,
all right?
But you,
what you,
what you're leaving out of all of this is that you're Killary Clinton acts like
she gives a shit about you as do all democrats.
They act like they give a fuck.
Most of them don't.
Most of them are no different than the Republicans.
And it's not even because they're bad fucking people.
It's because they're all grossly under fucking paid,
all right?
And most of them,
their careers die way before they ever even make it into the Senate and the
Senate.
You only make a couple of a hundred grand a year.
Now what the fuck are you going to do?
So what they do is,
is they take all these people's money,
okay?
They get themselves elected and then after they're fucking out of office and
while they're in office,
they hookup whatever fucking in the private sector,
um,
investments they have like all the,
like,
I forget what the percentage is.
Like senators,
they make a couple hundred grand a year.
They think they're all multi fucking millionaires.
They're all corrupt.
He says,
I just can't buy into this fantasy that,
that these Democrats give a fuck.
At least not these two I give.
I,
I believe that Obama cares more about the average individual than Donald Trump
without a doubt.
And Hillary Clinton,
she doesn't give a shit.
She doesn't give a fuck what?
All right,
whatever.
Let's read the rest of this and it tells them about Bubba.
So I get why you wouldn't like Clinton.
And I agree,
we liberals can be self righteous and annoying.
Okay.
And I think you're just begging us with the Clinton Trump equivalency stuff.
But I love you.
Well know that's you because you're so into Clinton.
I fucking hate Hillary Clinton.
You know,
if everything Clinton Trump did,
if you just took out the racism,
I wouldn't think he was as bad as Clinton,
but the fact that he's racist,
you know,
and just attracts those fucking people is,
that's the big rub.
That's the only thing.
But I am not snowed on any level by slick willy or this fucking idiot.
I really do not like them,
so I'm not just doing this.
Uh,
anyways,
she said,
I love you bill,
and I love America and I don't have a helicopter is to escape.
If Trump is elected,
well,
you need one to have.
Hilary is like Hillary's just going to do you like the direction the country's
going in because she is going to be more of the same.
It's going to be more of the fucking same.
MMM.
Whatever.
What the fuck do I know?
Both.
Whoever the fuck you want to vote for,
but please don't try to fucking anyways,
love you lodge.
Please vote for Hillary.
You knuckle dragging.
Troglodyte I don't even know what that means.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think like the level of panic that people have if Trump is elected,
I get that,
but I just wished there was the same amount of panic that then it's going to be,
it's going to be Hillary.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
neither one of them have talked about global warming.
Neither one of them talked about the population problem.
They haven't even addressed the heroin epidemic in this country created
allegedly by the pharmaceutical companies.
None of them talked about that shit.
They don't give a fuck.
Okay.
They ain't gonna do shit.
They're just going to keep making sure whoever,
whichever one of them makes it into the presidency.
All you think is going to change is that whoever wins is then going to become
even more wealthy because Trump's is going to greenlight any fucking golf
courses.
Some bullshit he wants to do.
Right.
I Dunno,
I'm so in over my head with his politics shit.
But I also,
you know,
one of the things about being a standup comedian and traveling,
you get to know people and you know when people are fucking assholes.
Okay.
You know,
and these two,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know.
I just uh,
this is a whole other level.
This is a whole other fucking level.
All right?
I really feel like it fucking annoyed the shit out all you guys just keep going.
Okay.
We get it built.
We get it.
All right,
here we go.
Dollar Shave Club.
Oh,
let's do a little advertising here.
I'll blow through these and I got a few more questions.
I swear to God they won't be political.
I really feel like I'm starting to be like Lenny Bruce,
like reading the fuck I,
but I only have a legal pad or any facts in front of me.
People vote who you want to fucking vote for.
All right.
Just do that.
Okay.
And then I'll shut the fuck up.
I won't,
I'll probably be making jokes about it and Unclick Ana Clinton on a Conan.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Guys,
you know,
you know to go to dollar shave club for a fantastic shave.
Well you probably don't know is that they have other amazing products to,
the quality is the best on the market.
Their bodywash is great and it won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post shave stuff keeps your skin soft and smooth.
There's stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like what?
How much money?
Everybody?
1 million bucks.
Okay.
Not Five grand,
dude.
If you found 700 bucks in the sidewalk,
you would be skipping down the street.
If you had crocs on,
they'd fly into traffic.
That's how,
that's how high step and you be.
Guilt don't went down the street.
Why is it gotta be a million million bucks?
650 grand after tax dollar shave club's got stuff for your hair.
I don't need that for your face.
I got a beard for Jaranda parts.
Everybody needs that for everywhere you need to keep and feeling and looking
fresh.
Uh,
once you're in the club,
you love the best grooming products out there and they'll all be affordable.
Right now is your chance to see for yourself why so many people love dollar
shave club.
If you're not a member yet,
you've never,
and you'd never joined,
now's the time.
Uh,
you'll get your first month of razors for free.
Just pay,
pay for shipping.
I can't read right now and it's only a few bucks.
Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave club.com/birth to boy
hanging their legal zoom.
Everybody is 2016 wides down.
Ask Yourself,
did you accomplish everything you set out to do this year?
If the answer is no,
legal zoom wants to help.
Say you'd like to finally get the dream business off the ground.
Say you'd find like to get that dream business off the ground.
Should you incorporate or form an LLC?
Maybe you have a great idea for a new product or an invention,
but no idea how to protect it.
Wouldn't it be great to have an attorney you can trust to guide you along
without breaking the bank?
Of course,
it was expensive.
Legal fees and questions shouldn't stand between you and making your dreams a
reality.
That's why legal zoom was created to provide a way for you to confidently
navigate the legal system with upfront pricing and complete transparency.
Completely transparent like fucking Hillary Clinton.
That includes legal advice from legal zone,
networked from legalzoom's network of independent attorneys,
licensed in 48 states.
They won't charge you by the hour.
Since legalzoom isn't a law firm,
uh,
there's no time like the present to take control of your future@legalzoom.com
enter,
burn the referral box@checkoutandsaveevenmoreatlegalzoom.com now,
that's legalzoom.com absolutely.
If you've got an idea for a business,
you've got to get that off the fucking ground,
you know,
so you can work for yourself.
Would that be nice?
A little swell.
A Miller.
All right.
Here we go.
A stamps.com everybody.
This last one,
then we'll get back to the questions here.
Um,
stamps.com sometimes it feels like there aren't enough hours in the day.
Geez.
Where does the time go?
Even when you're working past nine to five.
So if you're making time consuming trips to the post office,
you need a better way.
What is that?
Better way you stamps.com stamps.com you get postage the posts that you need,
the instant you need it.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package right from your
computer and printer.
It's quick and easy.
You'll save money with stamps.com it's a fraction of the cost of those expensive
meters.
Plus you'll get special postage discounts.
She can't even find it.
The office.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters for whatever Gig I'm doing.
I'm a more on if I can figure it out.
So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bird to get a four week trial plus a
$110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Gets statted with stamps.com today.
Within minutes you'll be printing postage right from your desk.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Bar B u r r a m
in the inbox.
All right,
there you go.
That's it.
Hey,
all you Hillary supports.
Where the fuck were you in fucking Bernie Sanders were around you guys all
fucking pussy out and you just got another fucking corrupt fucking cunt in
there.
And I would say con too,
if it was a guy.
So get you fucking tits in a fucking,
don't get your tits and a bunch now.
All right.
Yoga,
lunatic maniac,
Darryl,
Billy,
red tits.
Did you happen to catch the latest episodes of Hbo?
Real Sports with Bryant Gumbel?
Uh,
no I didn't.
I normally don't watch on a regular basis,
but felt compelled to check it out.
After hearing about this yoga guy on the Howard stern show,
apparently this nut job is the founder slash creator of Bikram Yoga named after
himself,
which has done all over the world and seems like it's got a crazy cult
following.
Basically,
people travel all over the world and spent over $10,000 to take his classes
because they believe he is some sort of spiritual leader.
Now,
allegations are coming out against him that he's sexually abused a bunch of his
students and made all sorts of derogatory remarks.
People cannot handle positions of power.
You know,
you can't have this guy.
Everybody listening to what he's saying and a bunch of people bending over in
front of them.
He's gonna take his dick out.
I mean,
how did you not see that comment?
Anyways,
he told Andrea Kramer,
who conducted the interview,
why would I have to harass women?
Uh,
people spend $1 million for a drop of my sperm.
He said that,
Holy Shit,
that's some of the greatest shit talk ever.
If that's fucking true.
What did she say?
He said,
why would I have to harass women people spend $1 million for a drop of my sperm?
Oh my God.
Did he fucking drop his lapel mic and walk off the set?
And when asked about whether he harassed a particular woman,
he said,
of course not.
I would never even piss on her face.
She's a psychopath.
This is a yoga instructor.
This guy sounds like an assistant coach.
He also said it sounds like a gym teacher.
He also said he's a million times smarter than any doctor and that every doctor
in the world comes to him.
Yeah.
This guy sounds like Donald Trump.
If he fucking ran a yoga class,
Donald Trump's got to put this guy in his ticket.
I grabbed the pussies.
He pisses in their face.
Trump room 2017.
Uh,
this guy seems like he's a little out of his tree.
Just wanting to hear what old freckles has to say about this.
I posted some links to the story slash video below.
Uh
Oh.
It's on the Huffington post I had,
I don't go to that website.
Those guys are out of their fucking weird man.
They always act like they're this really like big like,
like credible news source and then if you just look at the shit they have,
you know,
top 10 fucking celebrity nose jobs in the quarter.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I'll look for those links.
I'm not going to that website though.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking lunatic.
I got to see that man.
Great interview,
Huh?
It far is like,
yeah,
he's going to give you the quotes and as much as people at Ed Bryant gumbles
real sports were appalled.
They were,
they were secretly high fiving each other for the fucking ratings that that was
going to get.
He said,
well,
what did I get to read?
Go back.
What the fuck these,
why do I have to harass women?
People spend $1 million for a drop of my sperm.
Yeah.
That's what happens when people fly around the fucking world that come to your
yoga class.
People,
people go crazy.
They can't fucking handle it.
A girlfriend of seven years dumped me,
hey,
bill by girlfriend has seven years,
dumped me two months after she moved to Connecticut for Graduate School.
She didn't use those exact words,
but she told me,
she told me she needed time to think because something is missing in our
relationship and she needs time to figure out what it is.
Well Dude,
you been with them for fucking seven years,
man.
I mean,
who am I to talk?
I was with nearby for nine years before we got married,
but um,
we were on the same page as we were both terrified to fucking make that leap.
Um,
anyways,
I'm not a mind reader,
but if some,
someone has been with you for seven years and they need to time to think about
whether they still want to be with you,
that's not a good side.
Yes,
your instincts are correct.
I would say,
uh,
since I had this conversation with there,
I have been absolutely devastated and depressed.
I'm ashamed to admit this,
but the other night I found myself on my bedroom floor crying in the fetal
position.
Well,
that's totally normal.
And it's also,
it's a healthy thing to do.
Cry It,
rd it,
don't drink it out of you are fucking jump off a balcony.
Those are dumb shit that men do.
All right.
Women get down on the floor crying in the fetal position.
I think that's why they live longer.
If it was socially acceptable for us to do it.
So please continue doing that.
It's a valid human emotion that both men and women have that men fight.
Yeah.
Fucking cry it out of you.
Um,
good for you.
Very mature thing to do.
Um,
you should not feel ashamed at all.
And he said,
I understand that time heals all wounds,
but I have no idea how to chat to start the process of getting over this.
Do what you do,
what,
cry it out of you and then,
um,
call your best friend and just say,
listen,
do it.
I'm embarrassed to say this,
but I'm fucking devastated.
I'm over here crying like a little girl.
I got to get me out of the house,
man.
Take me for a fucking walk,
like a dog just to,
can we get some fresh air anyways?
He said to keep my mind off for,
I try to stay as busy by going to the gym and focusing on hobbies,
but I can't seem to shake this miserable feeling.
How would you handle this situation if you were in my shoes?
Um,
I would accept the fact that,
that it's going to hurt.
Okay.
And that you're not going to be able to just go to the gym and take a pottery
class and forget a woman that you love for seven years.
Um,
what do you have to do is understand that it's going to hurt for a while and you
have to,
rather than run from the pain,
sit in it,
cry your way through it,
and then go to the fucking gym
and you know,
the crying things going to last for a little while.
And once she gets through that,
then just try,
you know,
even during the crying time I tried to do,
I'm going to do something positive today.
I'm going to do the dishes.
You know,
just do little things that are on a list,
you know?
And then while you're doing that,
just started making a list of,
uh,
how you want to come out of this.
Do you want to come out of this ship?
The Shit he had?
Literally this shit 20 pounds heavier?
Or do you want to come out like 10 pounds lighter because you've been going to
the gym?
You know,
do you want to come out of this hating women or hopeful that,
that you,
you know,
you're with the wrong person and you haven't,
you have a whole new opportunity to meet somebody great.
You know,
you didn't have any kids.
You weren't married.
It's a fucking nice clean breakup.
Um,
you know,
you can totally rebuild your fucking life where you can have the greatest
fucking life ever.
And then one day you're going to run into her.
She's going to see how fucking happy you are.
And it's the fucking moment that you're going to want to be like,
yeah,
Hey Steve,
I'm happy.
Look at me and my car and my family.
And you know what?
If you're truly happy,
you're not going to have that.
Hey Fuck,
you think her,
you're going to be like,
hey,
how are you?
I hope you're happy.
You know,
and then you hate to be,
the greatest thing that ever happened is you fucking left me because now you,
dude,
you're older,
you're wiser,
you're going through this fucking thing.
Now you're going to really figure out what you like I'm telling you,
this will end up being the greatest thing that happened to you.
But the thing is you gotta.
You can't be a guy here and try to fucking block out the pain.
You got to fucking just sit in it.
You know,
just fucking go through Ali Shit that you bought together that makes you cry and
all that shit cry.
Put It on craigslist,
get it the fuck out of there.
You know,
get through all of that and then maybe just get rid of the shit that she got.
You move to a new fucking place.
Just fucking start over.
And then when you meet broads in a fucking bar,
you just tell them what's going on with deal.
Just got out of the seven year thing.
It was fucking devastating,
but I'm totally hopeful.
You know,
I want to meet somebody great,
and they're always like,
oh my God,
that's nice.
They're attracted to it.
Next thing you know,
you're drinking IPA,
she getting fucking blow jobs with women.
You're not in a relationship with looking at the clouds of party,
all right?
All of that shit is in your future,
but you got to go through the fucking paint first.
All right?
That's it.
If you are a car,
you're a fucking barn find right now.
They are even fucking fucking sprayed you off.
I've got the rat shit out of you.
You just got to deal with that right now,
but the best thing you could do is not buried this shit.
The reason why women do so well is because they're allowed to cry.
They can cry in front of their fucking friends,
they can talk the shit out and they can get past it.
We don't.
We fucking carry it and carry it and carry it in an effects other relationships.
If you truly want to fucking get past this thing,
you got to go through the pain of it.
That's what the fuck could I,
that's what I learnt all the fucking times.
I got dumped.
All right.
Good luck to you,
sir.
Go fuck yourselves to the rest of you.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
That is it.
Good luck with the voting.
Everybody may the best piece of shit when.